hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing black Branca from Brazil okay
wow I don't really remember how things
how this works okay I don't think this
can be totally terrible
looks like we transpose into some sort
of Sicilian jalapeno maybe e6 is another
thing you know not happy not happy about
this
I wanted something else and I've got
something else here with the saticons
okay so at least I didn't have any big
choice what is he doing here
that looks really strange moving the
Queen all over the place
I could have taken d4 you I mean this is
also fine but that e4 already was
winning
really hard
yeah I've got pretty good development
here 193 check
okay um do we have wind
somewhere somewhere over the rainbow
yeah laughter the Bishop g4 Queen takes
Knight if to it you can of course just
interpose that doesn't work I can take
on c1 and check on age six I just don't
know if there's anything better and as
possible it's not bad him so made on c1
would be good
Luke c1 made the Queen the Queen to d4
would help
not happy to go back with this but
Jim I didn't really refute this I mean I
might be winning but I did not refute
this to the fullest 24 is the point
so check rook takes c3 as possible
Bishop g7 loop d1 does not convince that
much if I take him and he's going to
play rook to d1 that's more an issue
okay Bishop g7 is fine I don't need to
do anything out of the ordinary
I'm also pulling up and I have the pair
of bishops and the bishops will be on
very nice spots so this is really okay
Bishop on g7 a strong Bishop on c6 will
be very strong as well on a5 on g4 it
depends currently I'm threatening rook
takes c3 still
yeah it's just totally I think what has
really no good move him
no move
[Music]
okay
yeah Roxie one the right moment
Roxie one takes takes Queen d1
doesn't doesn't immediately win
and now I'm winning this this Bishop it
was one point not queendom anonymous
they win the peace
yeah those bishops are quite good
yeah and white resins there are some
Bishop c4 lines that are quite okay I
mean this is not terrible option C for I
think but no even OC fire is correct and
no 93 I think is just um it's just a
Sicilian now just an olive hand yeah I
him the longest six looked a little bit
wrong but he played in such a weird way
nothing now white should mostly just
develop Knight c3 Knight f3 and claim
that my pawn structure is just rotten
that doesn't work at all I mean like
nothing not at all I have 94 even which
I missed I played this and I should have
taken on d4 immediately I mean this is
so quite bad I suspect it at 94 works
but Bishop in fact like this works it is
just one check and then it's over but
Bishop f5 is just like develop every
move develop the piece must be fine him
yes so here what was better actually
night 61 wasn't best Bishop g7 yeah okay
it is very nice but it wasn't super
straightforward when it seems and the
internist I heard +4 something I didn't
feel super obvious to me looks you want
what did I miss there
our bishops is six at the end or what
bishops is six huh yeah this is a good
move here looking at this and the knight
cannot means 25 okay you can check but
then you're out of all of its okay I
mean what I did is wins as well as many
as much leeway in such a position that
planned up the bishop but you don't
really have a good move I was thinking
this and then yeah rook see one here and
then Bishop c6 or so it should it should
be enough okay guys thanks for watching